hey guys I'm Abby sharp welcome to
Abby's kitchen today I've teamed up with
Sabra who are sponsoring this video
to bring you a delicious easy spring
side dish that is sure to become a
crowd-pleaser my zatar honey roasted
carrots with creamy hummus sauce with
the serve in the corner this veggie side
dish is perfect for entertaining because
it's basically like a vegetable candy so
even picky eaters are going to love it
and it's so easy to pull off using Sabra
hummus I love using Sabra to help me cut
back on the prep time because it's got a
really delicious smooth consistency and
a really authentic recipe with very
simple ingredients Plus Sabra is also
celebrating something this month April
is their 10-year anniversary so I'm
unofficially going to be calling this
the month of hummus either to get
started before I eat all the ingredients
so let's do this alright so I freaking
ate in my oven to 425 degrees Fahrenheit
I'm just gonna peel my beautiful carrots
here and I'm using a nice variety of
colors because they look really pretty
on the plate but you can use whatever
you can find at the grocery store and
some carrots are larger than others so
in some cases you've got to cut them in
half it's nice you've got to cut them in
quarters and sometimes you can just
leave them as is if they're nice skinny
ones I combined my carrots with some
olive oil melted butter cumin ends a
char and spread them out onto a baking
sheet so I'm just gonna pop this into
the oven for about 20 to 23 minutes
until they get nice and crisp tender
I removed the pan from the oven and
drizzle the carrots with honey we're
trying to back to the oven for an
additional 5 to 7 minutes or until the
carrots get tender and gently caramelize
finish with a sprinkle of fleur de sel
and keep warm so this is a light
flavorful and naturally gluten-free side
dish that is packed as fiber protein and
healthy fats so it's a nice herring
ferns otherwise indulgent Easter meal
now let's make our sauce in a small
saucepan I mix together a container of
Sabra classic hummus light coconut milk
cumin
lemon juice and a little bit of salt
stir on medium-low heat until smooth and
warm now we assemble see you don't have
to be in the kitchen all day to make an
amazingly impressive dish now it's your
turn
so visit Sapir Canada on Facebook and
show us how you plan to share Sabra
hummus during my unofficial month of
hummus so there you have it folks
zat are honey roasted carrots with a
creamy hummus sauce a tasty twist for
spring entertaining made easy and
delicious if you liked this video be
sure to give it the thumbs up check out
lots more videos by subscribing to the
channel and I'll see you next time on
Abby's kitchen
[Music]
[Music]